for these students school is now in a
monastery and home is a temporary
shelter in a camp for the internally
displaced they had to leave their
village when fighting between the
Myanmar military and the Archon army and
ethnic armed group that erupted in
January last year but to close there was
an airstrike they fired onto our village
our homes were burned artillery shells
hit our houses many have been here for
at least seven months and escaped with
little more than the clothes on their
backs
soldiers enter our village and we didn't
want to run into them so we ran away we
were scared they haven't been able to
return to their farms their shops and
are dependent on aid the UN says they're
near daily reports of civilians being
killed or injured and child casualties
are on the rise last month
more than a dozen students were injured
when an artillery shell hit their school
land mines also pose a threat
according to a recent landmine monitor
report by the International Campaign to
Ban Landmines
the government says it's doing all it
can to protect civilians we don't know
where the fighting is going to happen we
won't know ahead of the fighting we're
trying to do as much as we can we give
support to the people they get
compensation from the federal government
and the injured are treated for free at
our hospitals the our economy says it's
fighting for greater autonomy on behalf
of the Rakhine a mainly Buddhist ethnic
group who make up the majority here the
state is one of the poorest in Myanmar
and there's growing resentment towards
the government we win landslides in
Rakhine area but we cannot enjoy a
power-sharing resource area most
intellicus are not satisfied with this
condition but for the youth they became
radicalized the conflict has disrupted
aid services the UN office for the
Coordination of Humanitarian Affairs
says transportation routes used to
distribute food have been
affected and many aid organizations have
reported greater difficulties in
reaching more rural areas an internet
shutdown has made it more difficult to
get information on civilian casualties
and living conditions in the camps
Rakhine State is also where the Myanmar
military launched a violent crackdown
against the mainly Muslim Rohingya
minority more than two years ago Myanmar
which denies committing genocide has
been ordered by the International Court
of Justice to prevent further killings
of the RO hinga but as the conflict
continues civilians whether recline or a
hinga are being caught in the middle
Florence Lee al Jazeera booty dong
Township reclined state Myanmar